[Music]
all right so can you can you hear me
great so i think we're ready to start
now and uh
uh warmly welcome you to that
presentation here during the lunch time
and also one welcome to the online crowd
listening to that
and um yeah i'm very uh
excited to show you some of my research
so i'm david and i'm a researcher at
humboldt university here in berlin and
i'm part of the excellence cluster
science of intelligence where we look at
intelligent behavior at the individual
level at the social level but also at
the collective level
and yeah so my talk will present some
insights into individual differences in
behavior and how that scales up to
collective patterns
should work
yeah
all right so i want to start with with a
little uh picture out of a a kid's book
and this is elmar elma is that yeah
rainbow color checkerboard colored
elephant and it's a very famous book and
my kids like it as well
but i don't want to talk about elma i
want to talk about the herd of elephants
that elmer is living in and here it is
written that this herd of elephants
consists of young elephants old
elephants big elephants small elephants
thin elephants so all kinds of elephants
they're all elephants but they all
differ a little bit
and these differences within species
within even herds
are what interests uh what makes me
really fascinated and what i investigate
during my research
so yeah let's start a little bit more
basic though what is behavior
you see some examples of behavior you
see mating behavior you see migrating
migration behavior predator prey
behavior
and then foraging behavior and you see i
choose a lot of fishy examples so i
mainly work on fish i don't even work on
lion so i mainly work on fish because
fish are very easy to have in the
laboratory and you can have a large
number of individuals to investigate
their behavior
so
the thing that i want to show you is
that behavior can vary
and this variation in behavior is very
interesting for us
and i will explain that a little bit in
more detail so just have a look at
individual a
it's a fish
and that fish was
that fish
swim in such a round tank for four times
so we tested that fish for the swimming
activity four times and as you see yeah
this fish
it's from all the days a little bit
different
that is a variation that is within an
individual no one can perform a certain
behavior the very same way over and over
again so when we look at sports for
example you you all know that uh many of
yeah football players try to practice
penalties and to uh yeah be really
consistent in the penalty shooting but
then when it comes really to the to the
shootout some fail that otherwise uh
have never failed before so you can't
really do
a behavior in the same way over and over
again you would vary a little bit
but when we look at a second individual
let's call it individual b with also a
fish same size same age same sex and
this individual swam much more
and this is a variation among the
individuals
first the variation within an individual
but then the variation that is between
the individuals between certain
individuals there are
individuals that swim a lot that move a
lot they do certain things in their way
and then there are individuals that do
these things in a different way
one can plot that
so
what i mean is
individuals differ consistently
among each other
so you can always have a hierarchy of
the behaviors but they also differ
within
and this is what i mean over time you
can't really do the same behavior over
and over again at the same way so there
is within individual variation and there
is among individual variation
and for us as scientists we calculate
out of these two terms the so-called
behavioral repeatability which is simply
the fraction of the among individual
variations so the variation
among these individuals
uh
compared to the frac to the total
variation
and that gives us a hint how much of the
variation that we observe is really due
to individual differences
the question now is what generates
these individual differences
and what maintains these differences
and there are several hypotheses about
that first you need some initial
differences among the individuals and
yeah we believe that there are genetic
differences among individuals so the
genes are not the same in all uh of us
in animals it's the same but they're
also environmental differences the
environments where
animals grew up the environment
in that they were born all these
differences that were there at the day
of their birth in the very beginning of
their lives
but then there are also mechanisms that
reinforce
these initial differences to yeah
diverge
and that could be for example the social
me uh niche specialization that means
when you are in a group for example and
there is a dominant role in the
subordinate role these roles then
reinforce your behavior
or it means the pace of life theory
which is yeah a fast
moving individual will find food more
quickly
and then can grow more quickly
and a slow-moving individual can't find
food that quick so it will grow not as
quick as the fast-moving individual and
yeah
this is something that these initial
differences reinforce
and my question was now
is there really among individual
differences in behavior we can call it
personality is there personality when we
don't have these initial sources of
variation
it should be like this
it's easier to study fish right however
[Music]
there are materials and the only
mammals
who have the menopause are us
and all the others are sea based none of
the land-based mammals have the
monopoles i believe
i'm very convinced that matriarchy is
only with us and like whales and
dolphins so if you would it's not
my belief it's not only about which like
the leader of the pod will be or the
school of fish will be the one that
dreams faster
i believe
it's more about
like
learning
and
more complex behaviors so i would like
to ask if it's not only about measuring
like what fish swims faster and then all
the others follow it
fast as well but if
i think it's probably more difficult to
study dolphins than fish but if you have
heard about anybody studying matriarchal
thoughts in whales and everything
[Music]
i will come back to that leadership
topic in the later part of the talk but
of course their
animals differ in their social systems
and so you will find a very uh yeah
different social structures and a lot of
uh different animals
sure that that could be a reinforcing
factor as well
that uh can reinforce and these initial
differences so i don't
i don't say that is uh yeah all the
factors uh listed here so there are many
more factors that uh then influence the
behaviors
okay
so yeah
how can we how can we knock out
these initial differences that we assume
are there and knocking out the
environmental variability that is kind
of easy we can rear
animals here fish
in very identical environments we can
yeah grow plants and greenhouses under
very standardized very similar
conditions we can have light sources
that yeah provide the same light to all
the plants we can have fish for example
here in offshore
facilities in very standardized very
controlled ways so that all the
individuals experience the same
environments
and we can knock out the genetic
variability
by using clonal animals
so we all know probably about this clone
sheep dolly which was a artificially
created clone
some uh yeah decades ago but they're
also natural clones
so here these aphids it's a natural
clone then
in fish we find a lot of natural clones
and what means natural clone it means
that these species
have evolved
most often through a hybridization event
of closely related species and then yeah
after this hybridization there was one
individual that could reproduce clonally
and this one individual most often made
up then a new species so you will find
some species that reproduce clonally
that really produce copies of themselves
and these natural occurring clones
especially wordpress are an untapped
research for
our research on ecology and evolution
and especially
behavioral
ecology and evolution
so i want to introduce the amazon molly
because that is a fish that i use as a
clonal animal for my research and the
amazon molly it's not uh called after
the river amazon it's not from
the amazon river it's called after the
greek tribe of the amazon the all-female
warrior tribe because yeah this is all
female species there are no males in
that species and these uh fish these
females they yeah
reproduce by making small copies of
themselves
every 30 days they
give birth to live offspring that are
exactly the same as their mothers the
same dna
as i told you
which is the case for many clonal
species these species originated
by a hybridization event
a hundred thousand years ago two fish
a male a female of basilia mexicana and
a male of basilia lattipina they made it
and there was one individual that made
up then the colonel basilia formosa the
new species
interestingly they still need the sperm
of some closely related male species to
trigger their egg development
nothing
from that sperm is incorporated into the
egg but they need these sperm
to really get the act developed to uh an
embryo
so they're often uh that's why are
called sperm parasites we don't really
understand why the male still mate with
these females because they don't have
anything
from that except they might get more
interesting for their own females which
was one hypothesis that was brought up
in the 90s
okay so
we have this beautiful little fish a
little uh fish that can be reared in the
laboratory very well it produces uh
reproduces by giving birth to life
offspring we know the genome we know
that many of the results we could find
with these fish could be transferred
also to uh higher animals to
uh mammals and
in some cases also to humans so many
mental disorders in humans are
investigated in fish models because that
is cheaper and more easily to do
so
with that clone we can now ask is there
really no personality when there are no
initial sources of variation present and
what we did
in this experiment that i want to
explain here we took yeah seven
mothers and we took the offspring of
these mothers these mothers were clones
they were identical the offspring
identical and we separate them
straight after birth and we separate
them in in tanks that were similar
small aquariums that were similar for
all the individuals and then we yeah
raised them for about 50 days
under the same conditions the same water
condition the same light condition the
same food everything as standardized as
we could do
and then we looked at the behavior of
these individuals we phenotyped them
basically we put them into a round tank
and let them swim for a couple of times
so we see how consistent they are in
their swimming behavior
and yeah our hypothesis is this
so let's see what happens
so
yeah this is what happens we have four
observations
and here every uh every line is one
individual and we see there is a lot of
variation going on it's not
like this it's definitely not like this
and our statistics could prove that
there's a repeatability of 0.35
which means that
35 of the variation we see in that graph
is due to individual differences
so yes
there could be personality even without
initial sources of variation
they were yeah they had the same genes
they had the same environment but still
they differ consistently in their
behaviors
and now yeah the big question is when
and how does this variation emerge
and we had to do a next experiment to
really answer these questions and we had
three hypothesis for that the first they
could be different at the very beginning
of their lives so that pre-birth effects
could be critically important
so maybe there is something that makes
them
really different at the beginning of
their lives
more likely as we thought is that
feedbacks drive the immersion of these
variations so that over time they
develop into different directions and
when we then measure their behavior
after 50 days they differ
the last case could be that their
developmental jumps when certain hormone
levels uh change during the ontogeny of
the fish and then there are certain
phases in their life where there is a
yeah divergence of the behavior
so yeah how to investigate that how to
really look at these patterns
we decided to more or less build a big
brother system for fish so we separate
the fish at the very first day
in small standardized tanks
big enough to for the fish to show their
natural behaviors and then we put
cameras
on top of these tanks and we recorded
for 16 weeks
the whole day what they were
doing and that we did for yeah 40 fish
so we have a lot of data we have every
second of their life for the first 16
weeks
and now we can look okay when does this
variation emerge
the problem was okay we have this uh
huge amount of data
how to how to analyze that and we
developed a small tracking
software that could automatically go
through
all the videos and analyze how much the
fish were swimming and where they were
swimming
so yeah let's have a look what happened
and here you see the data of the first
90 days
and what we what we see here
looking at the distance moved
per day
is there is a lot of variation going on
and there is no pattern that the
variation yeah is getting bigger or
smaller or that there are jumps
so we find that 50 of that variation
could be linked to individual
differences
but what happened at the very first day
so we see there's a lot of variation all
ready there in the very first day of
their lives and when we zoom in
we see this so they were born with that
differences
they really had these differences at as
they were born interestingly
we found an effect of the moms
so the offspring of mom 3 were less
active than the offspring of mom 1.
and over time
we could see that the effect of the moms
is getting smaller and smaller though
they develop their own personality and
own individuality individuality over
time so here's the effect of the mother
and it gets smaller over time week by
week they
develop their own personalities
but overall
the overall variation is not changing
it's there the whole time
so
our idea is now there must be other
factors that influence
this behavioral variation this
personality
and some ideas are
for example epigenetic variation
so epigenetic variation we all know that
or at least we all saw that
we just have to look at ourselves so all
cells in our body have the same genetic
information the same book is in our
cells but in some cells for example
skin cells
only some pages are yeah red
and in our eye cells or our brain cells
that have the same book other pages of
that book are red
so
these pages that i read
they um this is meant with epigenetic
variation only certain pages of our
genetic book are red and that could be
also the case here in some individuals
the genes for a high movement are
activated or deactivated in other
individuals it's not the case and still
they have the same genome they're
identical but the pages that are read in
from their book of genetic information
that could differ
it could also be that they choose
different micro environments in their
tanks that some uh yeah
um
out of a sudden like to stay more in the
back some go more in the front even
these small standardized tanks so there
could be micro environmental factors
that then lead to the emergence
of this variation or there's
developmental noise
nothing like this but something that
is there during the embryonic
development inside the body of the mom
so that when they are born they are
already at this place here
we don't know at the moment but we want
to investigate that and especially this
epigenetics of behavior is something
that could be really interesting also
for us humans because we now know that
our childhood experiences and our
childhood
environments have a huge impact on how
we act how we um how healthy we are how
we act in our adult lives and
very uh yeah cool example how that
really works are these uh migrating
lookers with a solitary face you don't
even see these locus in nature when
they're in that phase but out of a
sudden
by an environmental trigger they change
their whole body their whole set up
and become
very gregarious and go together to
huge swarms millions and millions of
individuals that then yeah can eat empty
whole countries and this is just yeah
done by these epigenetic changes that
change the readability of the genetic
book
and we asked whether we can find
evidence for
something like this also in our in our
bodies and we tried or we decided to use
an environmental trigger that is very
common in fish and that is water
temperature
so even these fish
live very close to the uh to the tropics
they have variation of temperature in
their environments and they have to cope
with that so we can simulate that and we
simulated
this in a way that we took
sisters and four sisters
were reared at 28 degrees of celsius and
four sisters were reared at 22 degrees
of celsius so we had sisters raised
under high temperatures and sisters
raised under low temperatures
we raised them there or we kept them
there for 25 weeks then we put them into
an equalizing treatment which
means that they had intermediate
temperatures so to get rid of short-term
effects because we wanted to see whether
something really is a change that is
fixed
and then we tested them as we uh yeah
test our fish normally for physiological
performance how good they could swim
and how active they are
and what we find is yes
the environment can trigger
changes stable and fixed changes in
these animals they're still genetically
identical but the hot
fish those that were reared under high
uh higher temperatures
performed constantly
higher
in our swimming tests which means that
they're more active and they had yeah
most probably also different kinds of
muscle
structures that lead to that pattern
so there is evidence that epigenetic
changes can happen in these clones and
that might explain
why they are different even when they're
genetically identical
the next step now is to look really at
the genes
and we can do that by taking little
tissue samples that don't kill the fish
we look at the trans tryptome analyzers
which means we look at the proteins
or the rna that is really read out of
the dna and then we can link that
to our behavior measurements and then we
can hopefully pinpoint so just a look
into the future we can hopefully
pinpoint these genetic
yeah
areas
that are responsible for changes in
behavior that are responsible for the
development of personality
differences and i do that with
two experts from the us now
and we're at the at the very beginning
to understand how these epigenetic
effects and these transcriptomic
differences in clonal fish really work
okay to sum up that a little bit
natural clones enable us to minimize
genetic variability so a very
high set of very cool experiments can be
done with them but
these clones differ consistently in
their behaviors
and these behavioral differences are
there
from the very first day of their life so
very early on and there are maternal
effects so effects of the moms
detectable which is strange which we
yeah can't really explain at the moment
and we know now that environmental
triggers can change the readability of
their dna so environmental differences
can really induce differences in these
clonal animals
and
yeah
now your experts on individual
differences in behavior
and i want to stretch now to the
collective part of my talk
you see a lot of examples here for uh
yeah group living and the very nice
thing is that most of
uh
most of yeah basically all animals have
faces in their life where they group up
even if you think about uh yeah solitary
predators like
for example a pike in our rivers here
that uh yeah most of his adult life just
yeah stays somewhere hidden and waits
for another fish to come to attack that
another fish when the pike is small and
freshly hatched
the pike team up to groups because
they're afraid
of being eaten by other fish
maybe their own parents so the function
of grouping up
is safety to cope with predators
and many animals do that in certain
phases some stay uh gregarious some stay
in groups for all over their life others
only in certain periods of their life
but the function is more or less the
same for all these and yeah what does it
mean cope with predators or uh be yeah
in higher safety in a group
so there's some
hypotheses that are uh yeah brought up
to explain why living in a group
is really good for you when you're
living in a
dangerous environment the first is a
dilution of risk hypothesis just imagine
a predator can only eat one
prey individual per time
so don't think about uh yeah whales that
eat uh yeah millions of millions of uh
shrimps at uh at once but think about a
predator that attacks normally uh yeah
only one individual which is the most
common case
uh in the animal kingdom
and when you're alone and you meet a
predator then the chances that you are
the one that this predator will eat is
about 100 percent
but when you meet a predator and you're
in a group of 10
vretta will eat one of these 10 in the
woodland so yet rest to get eaten is
only one-tenth
and this is a dilution effect
you can dilute the risk of getting eaten
when you're in a group when the
predators can only pick single
individuals
the next thing is you can maybe detect
the predator earlier on
because yeah when you're alone you can
only look into certain directions at a
same time but when you're in a group
many eyes can screen the environment so
it's easier for you to detect the
predator early on and do you can then
probably react better and faster and
earlier and so you increase your chances
to survive the predator encounter
but
also more sophisticated behaviors become
possible when you're in a group you can
really do behaviors that confuse a
predator and so lower the risk of a
successful attack
and here's an example of my research
from mexico
you see a
a kingfisher an ice vogel that attacks
a big swarm of small fish
and you see these these water ripples
here but you also see
other water ripples
here
and also here
these are done by the fish
these are done by the fish collectively
diving down
they do it in a way that resembles la
ola waves that we are yeah know
from
football stadiums
it's a mexican fish so uh we also call
it the mexican waves because the laola
waves were first appearing during the uh
i think
1986
world championship in mexico so
they are really doing mexican waves
and it's a behavior that helps them
to confuse the predator whenever the
kingfisher sees these waves it waits
longer to attack
the next time
and when the kingfisher is waiting
longer to attack the next time your risk
to get eaten yeah gets lower and lower
because it can't attack in a staccato
so this is a
nice example how
groups can perform certain behaviors
that really distract and confuse
predators
and the next point here is we want to
understand how groups can do that
and what we have to do is yeah we have
to analyze how
individuals in groups really behave how
they interact with each other how much
time they spend with each other how
close they come to each other hopefully
then we find some rules that they apply
uh to act in synchrony to act
collectively to act coordinatively to
perform certain uh types of collective
behavior
and based on analyzes like this that i
showed here the tracking of individuals
there were three rules postulated that
help all animal groups to maintain
cohesion to move uh collectively into
the same directions and
i will explain these rules uh in brief
so the first rule is when there is no
one around you but you see some of your
account specifics uh more far away you
move to them
this is you get attracted by your
account specifics and these this
distance that attracts you that can
differ between species so the fish
certain centimeters uh yeah is enough
and they swim to the others in humans
maybe other distance apply
the next thing then is the next rule
then is when you're close enough to your
con specifics that they are in an
optimal distance to you you move into
the same direction
so you orientate with them and that's
why we see often um yeah swarms and
shoes and um yeah big herds moving very
synchronously they're on this uh in the
right distance to each other so they
orientate to the same direction
but of course that can be the case where
the others come too close
and even fish have this private distance
where they don't want to have another
individual to be
within and so you move away when the
other comes too close not to bump into
it
and with this three rules we can really
simulate collective behavior as it uh so
it looks like a life swarm a fish a herd
of angulad and it looks like this
this is a simulation based on these
rules and you all can do that yourself
just go to that website and try it you
can modulate the speed of uh those
artificial
fish you can modulate all the zones the
distances that they have and then you
can look how that changes collective
patterns within
this school of fish
it's a very cool website by the brockman
and there are a lot of
more cool stuff to explore there
but
the thing
is still have individuals and in the
first part we learned individuals differ
in the first part we learned a lot about
individuality and individuals yeah they
differ from each other in many traits
not just behavior but also size and age
and sex
and they mutually influence each other
when they are in a group so
you always have this uh yeah you ask for
leadership and
some
in some groups there are fixed leaders
and others there are leaders that change
their roles and individuals in fish
schools and large fish swarms they
change the leader rule constantly when
someone has more information
where is food where's the predator and
then this one act as a leader and so
they can change
within the group who's the leader
they all mutually influence each other
and they're not easy to control
i mean you can't tell them to change
their rules of interaction you can't
tell animals to really change how they
do their social interactions and that
hemp is our um yeah experimental uh
facilities to really test whether these
rules that are proposed are the real
rules in these swarms so what to do then
what to do how to investigate
individuality in swarms how to
investigate the rules of these swarms
when you can't really
control the individuals
so in a perfect world we would like to
bring this
model by the brockman into a live
fish swarm or a live herd
and we can do that
we can take control of some individuals
in the groups
we can do that
by integrating
artificial
animals inside groups this is a
superfish robot
this is
a siemens fighting fish robot that can
be integrated into a group
and this is a yeah
the guppy robofish that we have here in
berlin you can yeah you can go and
yeah let this robot
swim yourself in the dutch laws in the
humboldt forum there's a exhibit where
you can really steer it not with live
fish but with virtual fish but it will
explain you how it works
and we believe that using these
artificial agents that we can integrate
into live animal groups will help us to
study
the um the social behavior and the
collective behavior of animals and we
recently um yeah summarized our ideas in
that article and there's a
huge number of researchers now that try
to make these robots better that not uh
just having these
more or less yeah artificially looking
uh robots in a group but that really
develop animal or artificial animals
that you can't distinguish from the live
ones and so the live fans can't
distinguish them from other live ones
which is a very uh big benefit when you
want to integrate them into
a group of live animals
and this is done by
tim he's a professor at the free
university and he works a lot with these
fish
robots he also developed a b robot that
could uh yeah reenact the waggle dance
of the bee so that a-shaped uh dancing
and could really lead bees to certain
positions around his stalin campus where
then the bees
flew out to find the food sources that
he uh has hidden there
all right so how does it work
so that's me that's a robot
and
it's a tiny rubber mate fish and below
the rubbermaid
dummy we have
a food and here there are two small
magnets
and these two small magnets they yeah
face down
and down
below the tank there's a robotic unit a
small card that is uh yeah steered
by wi-fi
and this
has a magnet on top so we can couple
the uh the dummy fish with the robot
unit
and so the robot unit won't get wet
and we can then yeah steer the robot
unit through the tank very easily and we
can put live fish in that tank
so in our lab it's not looking that
fancy we had to go to the males museum
in charleston to do that movie so it's
not that cool bluish in our labs but it
works the same way
so here's an example of an experiment
that we did
we programmed the robot to just drive a
tic-tac path
through the tank
the live fish left the refuge and then
it followed the robot first to that
corner and then to that corner
and we can
we can repeat that kind of experiment
the next day the next day the next day
the next day so we can test the same
individual over and over again with the
same social environment
because that robot is not changing
um
its behavior we can test many
individuals with the same social
environment so we can see how they
differ in their social behavior and when
you do that a lot of time
on the left
the robot track on the right the live
fish track when you do that a lot of
times with a lot of different fish you
find some fish follow very closely
and then you find some fish yeah they're
not interested in the robot at all
and these individual differences in the
social ability
can be investigated very nicely with
such kind of
non-reactive robots
but okay yeah it you would say yeah it's
not a robot you could uh do it yourself
uh by driving it uh
yeah by hand through the tank but we can
also program the robot to interact with
the live fish in real time we have
cameras on top that track the behavior
of the live fish and then we can tell
the robot stay close to that live fish
as we did here
here the robot
here the robot was programmed to just
follow the live fish
keep a certain distance drive the same
speed as the live fish follow the live
fish closely and it's an yeah
autonomously driving car more or less
with a robot dummy on top
and what we can
answer with this kind of experiment
we can ask or answer what happens to a
group
in this case a pair when some
individuals
are fast moving some individuals are
slow moving and what we found here
when there were live animals that were
really fast moving
the pair
or the distances between the individuals
was very high
so the faster the live fish moved the
yeah the less the robot could uh yeah
make really the distance uh consistently
slow but they were all heading into the
same direction when they were fast
moving when they were slowly moving
say more or less were uh yeah
chaotically
orientated so the speed of just one
individual in that group that was a
leader in that pair yeah really defined
the collective pattern that emerged in
these pairs
so the individual differences of the
live fish had a huge impact on the
collective pattern that we see here
of course that was a pair
and
this is more a group
and our aim is now to integrate the
robots into bigger groups but to also
investigate what happens in bigger
groups better and we use
more
or newer techniques
that enable us to
simulate what is the fish seeing
who's in the visual field of the fish
because that is very important only the
animals that the fish can see are the
animals it can interact with
most of that is ignored and uh yeah in
theoretical models so we
look
who the fish sees
and we can now ask
really has the individual differences as
we found in the pairs an effect on how
the group performs when the group is
bigger
we show that with the robot okay yeah
the individual has an effect on the
group on the pair but what happens
when we use for example bigger pairs or
bigger groups
with four individuals eight individuals
16 individuals or 32 individuals and
that was a
experiment by alessandra and fritz you
see here during field work yeah we
really asked can we
can we find out how a group
behaves by knowing how the individuals
in the group behave alone
and what we did is yeah we tested first
all these four individuals in the groups
alone
getting known uh how yeah how much they
differ what their swimming personality
was
and then we tested them as a group
we put them in a bigger tank
we put some obstacles into the tank and
we observed them for a couple of times a
couple of weeks repeatedly inside this
big tank
and what we found was
okay there is individual variation
i showed that in the beginning
the fish that we tested alone they all
differed in their speed
interestingly
we found
much higher
differences among the groups so group
five let's say was very slow
and group yeah let's say 10 was very
fast
and yeah our hypothesis was those fast
moving individuals should be then in the
faster group and those small
move
those uh yeah not so uh fast-moving
individuals should yeah be in the slower
groups
and you can correlate that
and what we find is no
there is no link between the individual
speed so the swimming
activity measured alone and the swimming
activity of the group
everywhere
[Music]
how to explain that
and then
one of my colleagues came up with a
with a study made on humans or done in
humans and he said yeah well maybe
the speed of the individual is not the
factor that really influences the group
speed maybe it's how the individuals
interact within the group that define
the speed of the group and there was a
study on humans that tested how uh good
groups of humans can solve highly
complex uh problems so how intelligent a
group is and they also measured the
intelligence
of the certain group members and they
couldn't find a link so the individual
intelligence was not linked to the group
intelligence but they found that the way
they talk to each other inside the group
that defined how good the group really
could solve these complex problems and
how how equal they shared their speech
within the group was a big factor so the
more equal the uh the speech was shared
among the group members in these human
groups the better they could solve the
problems and yeah unfortunately the
groups of more females with more women
uh yeah uh were superior in this
experiment uh because in groups that
were dominated by males one male was uh
most often speaking the whole time and
not allowing to equally share the speech
so similar things could have happened
here so that our uh measures of
individual speed are not the factor that
really influences then the group speed
so to sum up that
individuals are often part of larger
collectives as i told you in many
species
then yeah it's very hard to measure
individuality within group because they
all differ they all influence each other
and we can use a robotic fish to really
yeah get control of some individuals
inside the group and then investigate
how groups really work
and these interactive robots allow us
then to really prove ideas how
collective patterns can
emerge but there are several things we
don't understand at the moment for
example why is there not a correlation
between individual performance and group
performance and these
additional factors as i explained in
that human study that might play a role
here
okay so i will close my talk with um
yeah showing you a little bit um yeah
why
this kind of research is relevant
also for our lives so we're getting more
and more and we yeah we live more and
more in cities
we live very packed we live in groups we
like to go to yeah to watch football or
uh to go and hatch in mecca we like to
yeah group up
we like to go to concerts uh yeah this
event culture is increasing and as a
byproduct
accidents can happen
many people die in these groups because
there are too many people at the same
time at the same spaces
they get crushed because we don't really
understand how groups work
how much
policeman and woman do you need to
control a group of humans to get out of
a dangerous area or to control a group
in a way that not all the people want to
go through one tunnel like it was uh
yeah the case during the lost parade uh
accidents in duisburg where a lot of
people died so knowing how groups really
work can help us
to make our event culture
things more safe
so we can really increase the safety of
ourselves by knowing how much people are
yeah the maximum that should be in a
certain place how many policemen and
women do you need to control a group
of humans how many you need to evacuate
a stadium in case you have
to but yeah we have to prove that the
rules that i explained for animals are
also uh the rules that apply to human
groups
and that was done by uh jens krause in a
television show quarks and co a couple
of years ago
he rented a gym and invited 200 people
and they were all told
to follow these simple rules always move
always keep an arm length distance to
your neighbors and don't talk and don't
gesture what you're doing or don't
interact
other than with these two rules with
your uh yeah with your roommates in that
case
and an additional rule was that some of
these people were told to go to certain
places in the gym go to the place of the
sign one or the sign 16. so they were
given information where to go
and then we can yeah we can really look
what happened
so over time
some individuals in that group were told
to go to one
and some to
nine and you see what happens here they
didn't talk they just walked they just
followed their neighbors in an arm
length distance
and in the end you get
really
this pattern you can control a group of
humans without talking to them just by
having a certain number less than 10
of the group knowing where to go
and that is a very important insight for
people that organize uh
big events with big crowds because then
they know where
and how many uh yeah policemen they need
woman they need to really make this
event a safe event
and
at the end of my talk i want to show you
this little clip i'm really fascinated
by that clip so for for several reasons
so the first reason
this professor in the u.s did that
experiment i think a thousand times and
at the end of that clip you will see
he's still shocked by the outcome so
that is that is also me when i look at
animal behavior i know
a lot about animal behavior i've
observed a lot of animals i'm still
fascinated by their behaviors when i
look at it
like this professor he's still shocked
he did that experiment i think a
thousand times still he's fascinated by
the outcome
ah but it also tells you
that tiny things can have a huge impact
tiny differences even among clonal
animals can have huge impacts on
big groups and that's yeah
the end of my talk and i thank you very
much for listening to
my talk and i want to thank also my
collaboration partners all over the
world without them it won't be possible
to do that that kind of research and i'd
like to thank uh my phd students that
did most
of uh the experimental work i showed
here yeah thank you very much and i
think we can have some yeah questions
afterwards
[Applause]
hi uh firstly thank you for the talk it
was super interesting um
talking about the robot fish um is there
much research to suggest that they treat
it as another one of their species or is
it or is it another fish type that they
would interact with the same way or yeah
i guess that was my question so when we
when we first started to to investigate
live fish with robotic
fish they didn't react to the robot uh
really well so they ignored it and then
uh yeah someone came up with the idea
oh we we should
we should not paint eyes on our models
we should glue little glass eyes on the
models and edward's the secret
so we
we asked for
for little glass eyes that are normally
used for kit toys for teddy bears and we
attached these little glass eyes to our
3d printed replica of a fish and then it
they started to get interested in that
so
this really uh yeah niko tinberg
called that schlisselrites
it's a key feature that this robot has
to have
to get the other live fish
interested in it and uh most probably
yeah something in these eyes is glaring
or as reflections made the fish really
believe okay that is a con specific that
is another fish i want to follow or i
want to interact
okay so
science is often really concerned about
finding things that are true across many
individuals so what's it been like for
you as a researcher looking at just the
the differences between individuals
have you had difficulty getting funding
or what's it like to convince colleagues
that
this sort of work is also important to
do
you mean uh because i work on uh
individual differences whether that is
um
oh no i think i think people are really
interested in that because uh yeah we we
observe these individual differences in
us
so uh yeah we're all different and uh
even uh twins are different and with
that's this kind of uh research i can do
twin studies in a much better and much
more controlled much larger
scale than it would be possible with
humans or other mammals and this really
helps us understanding uh yeah how
individuality how personality emerged
this is a topic that really people are
interested in and even if you if you
would live alone in a in a cave
somewhere you will see that all your
cockroaches in your cave will differ in
their behavior so you're always getting
into contact with
behavioral differences in your
environment in the animals you live with
or you can observe and also with your
peers of course
um so i already asked you before i would
like to ask you again if you if you know
any studies using um
citizens like so um
whales or if you yourself are interested
in studying uh whales because because of
our reproductive behavior
the only animals that are like us are
dolphins and whales so it will be
interesting to do something like
material pots where there's like a
female elder female like they call it
like the grandmother effect who kind of
take care takes care of society and i
believe it's easier to study with fish
however it can lead to more simplistic
conclusions about speed and i agree that
there are stuff like chaos theory right
we have the butterfly effect and
everything and it is interesting to
study that just the mechanics if you use
fish it's very easy you can do some
study with fish and then you realize the
butterfly effect or whatever
but it's more mechanical and i think it
might lead to wrong conclusions in the
sense that they are right like
in the physics but then socially if we
apply that i think we actually made a
mistake like what was it 100 years ago
like jade how is it jane goodall or
other people who were studying primats
and they we tried to use that
what we learned from primates but our
behavior is very different from private
because they are very primates are very
like patriarchal and there is like a
strong male and we are so much different
in terms of our
reproductive behavior so i think if you
know anything about whales or if you're
interested maybe you can try to do
anything about how does
uh a group
move
with a like a grandmother like the orca
right there's like a orca grandmother
who leads the pulse to some kind of
teaches them there's a lot of learning
and tool use and everything so if you
know anything about similar studies or
if you have any ideas
so
yeah that's uh first of all i'm
i'm presenting the rules that we found
out i'm not the one that has to judge
how these rules are then applied in a
society we can observe uh yeah what
happens in animals and we can postulate
that these rules might then apply also
to human groups or even to
uh yeah to the spread of information in
social media
the same yeah social networks that we
all know with facebook and twitter and
so on
the rules
are part of the interactions and groups
as well and we can study how information
flows within a group the same way as we
can study how information flows through
the internet this is something yeah we
can look at and
i'm not here to or my research is not
based on uh making them judgments for
the society i present that's going on
and then the political leaders the
elected political leaders they can take
that information and make the judgments
that we all need to uh to do or to have
but uh i'm not the one that makes these
such uh judgments uh regarding uh your
uh your question about
reproductive
structures and differences for the
movement there is a group in at the
university of konstanz that works on
baboons
and
yeah so i'm not an expert on how our
social system was uh 200 or 2000 years
ago and uh basically uh what we observed
today is maybe not the uh
the the things that uh yeah the humans
evolved in uh so that uh we don't really
know how how human uh evolution went on
uh over the last uh yeah hundred
thousand years and what uh social
systems we had and how these influenced
uh our group living so uh i'm definitely
not the expert for that i know that uh
in some animals uh the social structure
has a huge impact on how they move and
how they define uh who
inter or who starts the movements in the
baboons
the they have a very strong
yeah structured hierarchy with some
males being on top but those males they
don't uh yeah they don't
start the movement it's uh the other way
around uh some females start the
movements of the groups so and the males
then follow so no one will would follow
a baboon male in the wild uh
yeah they are not the ones that interact
and move though they start the movements
uh most often so other individuals that
might have more information where to go
might be more important but it is highly
species and population dependent
look at uh yeah the pun and the bonobos
so they're basically the same species
they differ totally in their social uh
structure how they live so it's highly
uh dependent what patterns you find on
uh the species and the population and
the environment that these populations
live in and you always have to take all
this into account when you want to make
yeah inferences about what your data say
so
i can't give a general answer to that so
i'm not an expert on the human system
and uh i just know we have to take a lot
of things into account to really make uh
yeah
judgments uh how
things will be or how things will work
but we can we can definitely talk about
that later so if i didn't really hit the
answer
yeah so i'm interested in the fact that
you've said that this behavioral um
variation
research especially in fish have been
done before to know more about the human
human things such as mental health can
you maybe explain the correlation
between this behavioral variation and
the mental health in human again can you
repeat
can you please explain the correlation
between the behavioral variation in fish
and the
mental health and human because i don't
really understand
the
the the individual in the group sing in
humans
yeah it was
basically we can't find that the
individual speed
in our fish
defines how the group moved so how fast
the group was
and the human study i mentioned
they asked what are the intelligence
uh of certain group members define how
intelligent the group will be so they
tested uh
the uh
the man and uh women in these groups
independently for their performance in a
iq test or in some more complex
uh tests and then they group them
together to group and then they
investigated whether the group could
solve similar uh tests better when the
group were composed of more
uh intelligent individuals and that was
not the case there was no other
correlation same as we find here with no
correlation between the individual speed
and
the collective speed the group speed and
for humans it was found then yeah how
they shared their speech how equally
they interacted with each other that
defined how um yeah how good they were
in performing in these intelligence
tests and group of more females they
were more equally sharing the speech
they were more equally talking to each
other and so these groups were
outperforming those groups that not
equally shared their speech that are
most often uh dominated by one or two
males so that is a case for humans and
we think that similar uh yeah factors
that not relate to the to the observed
behavior not related to the speed
could have an impact here how the
individuals in our fish group interact
with each other how close they came how
what interaction rules they used that
could have made a difference that we
find in the group behavior
all right then i hope you enjoyed a
little bit and thanks for coming
[Applause]
[Music]
you